hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to another impossible let's
play I'm playing Disney Fantasia music
evolved but I can't just do it normally
so I got these electroshock therapy
things that are gonna make my muscles
twitch here's how they work if you can
see that so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna play this game when I'm oh oh what
Who am I I have no idea oh boy this is
actually one of the few times that I'm
able to use some cool music without
paying a penalty for it so I'm gonna
play one of the spell god why are you
stopping me ah
oh that's right I play the actual game
not the song browsing wiser timer
countdown is that until when I die from
these things I've been ressure this is
not lethal in any way there's used for
therapeutic purposes so I'm not in
danger okay so I'm back at the main menu
I'm gonna play or not the main menu of
this selection screen for the actual
songs and I'm gonna play Lords Royals
because like I said this first time I
can actually use cool music real
licensed music in a video uh so if you
don't know about this game it's made by
Harmonix they're the guys that made
Guitar Hero and all those other cool
stuff with rhythm games and so this
one's kind of the same but since it's
Disney Fantasia what you're gonna do is
you're going to conduct a symphony about
the song that you picked so you pick
various instruments with your I did not
pick that but that's okay I think it's
kind of confused right now
go down there we go you gotta like push
forward for the circles and then you
gotta oh boy here we go ah yeah and then
you gotta do the thing ah so obviously
you can see how this is going to be
difficult oh here we go oh that's nice
it's actually a lot of fun we just did a
tournament I can't tell you about the
outcome of it but it's out at the same
time oh you can see exactly what
happened everywhere else on Polaris and
you could see oh we had a tournament
driven cinnamon toast cannon
I won a Macallan senor rubriz you serve
me right now oh why did isn't pink Oh Oh
God wires huh Oh shoulder oh okay
well I can't exactly think of any
commentary right now because I'm in a
bit of crisis mode but as you can see
you it's a very pretty game is pretty
responsive it's all the connection oh ho
ho oh and what this is is a special solo
mode so if you get these conducting
moments with Fantasia awesomeness done
correctly you can unlock a solo that's
gonna be special for the song that
you're playing I'm not sure I'm gonna
get it now because here we go come on
woman there we go got it okay oh god one
Lavelle up where'd it go
oh god that was my ab one I didn't even
show where these were I got them hooked
up all over my butt oh who did that
oh I got it no no I got I got don't
touch the thing okay so it's a solo deal
I need to turn up okay so it's a solo
thing where you get to make up your own
aspect to the music can I get this off
ah oh now I can hear the music ah
pulsing oh why does it keep pausing like
that so you you move this to make your
own rhythm to get the wobb wobb into the
lord song oh there we go it's nice to
actually hear the music now well you
guys could hear the music fine I just
come here I got a whole crew of people
that are just laughing at what an idiot
I am behind the scenes here I'm over at
maker
it's like they got a bunch of people
just stand around wondering who the hell
I am and why I'm dipping
heck even I don't know why I'm doing
this it goes a little like this routine
that just loops back and over and I
actually did this during the tournament
Bob's me and up deal the other guys did
the surge the tournament oh they know I
know it's not the most fun horrible ah
it's not quite as bad as that
electroshock game I did it's just cuz I
have a lot of them is it the involuntary
aspect of it oh just imagine a Mickey
Mouse on Fantasia Hill being the Wizards
apprentice
oh I didn't even do that one oh okay
kind of counting down math there we go
it actually is pretty responsive like I
made fun of the Kinect if you guys saw I
did my Zumba fitness video with Wade and
we're kind of making fun of the Kinect
but this is gonna actually works really
well a little bit of lag
I can't even say it's perfect it's a
little bit of lag but as far as coming
from the original one I'm not even a
console gamer there's not bad oh okay oh
boy here we go
let me just crank it up to maximum just
in case I in the Sun oh that's good oh
oh oh am i drooling that's cool okay I'm
done all right you guys could stop
laughing at me now
okay so that was Disney Fantasia music
involved is the full name of the game
that's coming out I don't know when is
it coming out soon it's coming out soon
says someone behind the scenes so thank
you all so much for watching
I promise this wasn't gonna kill me I
don't think it would guy but does still
don't do it at home I don't even know
what this is
but anyway thank you all so much for
watching you can check out the other
stupid stuff
done to her myself I've eaten hot sauce
I ran a treadmill while playing game
took an ice bath all sorts of cool stuff
check it out the playlist in the
description below her over there thanks
again everybody and as always I'll see
you in the next video bye bye